today I am joined by a very special
guest speaker dr. Daniel barreto dr.
barreto is a lecturer in the management
science and engineering department at
Stanford University and also the chief
software architect for wise technology
he joined wise in 2003 and is
responsible for the architecture and
software innovation for the company
growing their software portfolio with
new award-winning products resulting in
over 50 patent applications 23 of those
listening Daniel as inventor or
co-inventor his organization takes a
leading role in incubating new
technologies with tcx vda and
pocketcloud being some of the successful
releases dr. barreto is also responsible
for collaborating with partners
customers and standards groups on
strategic areas in the IT industry prior
to joining wise Daniel was a staff
engineer at IBM in the systems and
storage division he has been working
with desktop virtualization since its
earliest stages dr. Brett o holds a
master's and PhD degree in electrical
engineering and management science and
engineering from Stanford University and
a bachelor's degree from Purdue
University dr. Brett oh thank you very
much for joining us today Thank You
Michelle and thank you to everyone
joining us online let me start by giving
you a quick overview on what we're going
to be covering today in the webinar
we'll start with a quick recap on what
virtualization is for those of you who
are not familiar with it will continue
by looking at some of the market data
behind server virtualization and desktop
virtualization to try to put things into
perspective we'll continue by describing
some of the desktop challenges that IP
is facing today with traditional PCs and
then we'll continue by by talking about
desktop virtualization one alternative
to desktop computing that has emerged in
the last couple of years as an
alternative to to overcome some of the
challenges that I t is facing in desktop
virtualization we'll talk about
different deployment at architectures
that technologies will talk about the
ecosystem important deployment factors
that one needs to take into account
and the challenges and benefits overall
there's going to be a lot of information
to cover in this space and we have
limited time in this webinar so we'll
try to touch get some of the main points
I understand that the slides are going
to be available offline after we finish
with the webinars well I've also try to
include some data that you guys can
print after the laminar these are so
with that said let's get started what is
virtualization let's let's talk about
the components in a physical machine
first in a physical machine one has
hardware one has an operating system
that runs on top of the hardware and one
has the applications that get installed
on top of the operating system as we can
see in this picture all those three
components I are tightly coupled and
that's why they are shown as puzzle
pieces if one wanted to deploy a
different server with the same
components one would have to go over the
installation and configuration of all
the different components once again so
in this particular example we we have
microsoft exchange server running on on
on windows and when the IT manager we
want if the IT manager wanted to have
additional servers they would have to
deploy the additional components as we
can see in the in the following slide in
this example we have three different
servers the database server Citrix
server running in different operating
systems so as you can see now IT
managers have to manage all these
individually and I need to configure and
deploy them individually in
virtualization on the other hand instead
of installing an operating system
directly on top of the hardware one it
starts a hypervisor the hypervisor
abstracts the computer resources the
hardware resources from the operating
system and this allows one to have
multiple virtual machines running
different operating systems on top of
the same power in the context of server
virtualization it is very important to
optimize the CPU the virtualization of
the CPU the virtualization of the memory
the virtualization of the storage and
the virtualization of the network
since those are the main components the
components I need to perform very well
with with servers in this example we now
have all three servers running on the
same hardware and as we can see there's
different operating systems finding
without conflict the bond between the
operating system and the hardware has
been broken and so virtual machines are
now portable deploying or copying
virtual machines is now as simple as
making multiple multiple copies of file
server virtualization has been very
successful in the last couple of years
because it has major benefits first and
foremost we have hardware consolidation
which allows us to run the same
workloads with less physical servers
this offers better Hardware utilization
and resulting in major savings in
investment of capital there's a
significant reduction in space
requirements for the data centers less
energy consumption and less cooling
required for those data centers there's
also very rich management stacks and
centralized tools to manage virtual
machines which simplifies simplifies the
professional the provisioning and the
deployment next we have significant data
recovery and high availability benefits
if a physical server goes down VMs can
be migrated sinlessly to different
hardware or even different data centers
and finally we have application
oscillation since it's easy to deploy
new servers 11 can have most different
servers dedicated to different
applications to make sure that there's
no conflict between applications running
on the on the same server so let's look
at some of the market data for
virtualization based on the latest
numbers from IDC the server
virtualization related ecosystem was
thirty billion dollars in 2009 and it's
expected to grow to 68 46 billion
dollars by 2013 the virtualization echo
system includes the virtualization
software the management the server
hardware and the
services which are integration services
consulting services support and training
services this is a well-understood
market where the main player is vmware
and there's all other heavyweight
companies such as Microsoft fans Red Hat
and Citrix which have been making major
investments in the space this is also
important to note that this
virtualization server virtualization is
a key technology enabling cloud computer
cloud computing services now let's focus
our attention on a new trend that trend
of virtualizing to desktops server
virtualization has been so successful
that people are now looking at the
benefits the potential benefits of
virtualizing the desktops since the
number of desktops in IT shop is
significantly higher than the number of
servers the potential for these market
is to actually over grow the server
virtualization market in 2009 it was
estimated that the market was one point
billion baht 1.5 billion dollars and
it's estimated by that by 2013 that
market curve which north of 65 billion
dollars representing forty percent of
the professional PC market there has
been major acquisition and a
consolidation activity in this space as
we will see in the coming slides since
the desktop workload is now all running
on the server one that doesn't need a
full pc running on the desk anymore then
that's why this goes hand in hand with a
thin client industry thin clients are
devices like a setup box that i have
just enough operating system they run an
embedded operating system so they can
connect remotely to virtual machines in
the in 2009 this in this market we
shipped 3.2 million units and it's
expected that by 2013 we will be
shipping over 24 million units so let's
try to understand the pc desktop the
challenges for PCs and why people are
looking at desktop virtualization as one
potential solution there are many issues
that I teashops face today in delivering
the user desktop the costs associated
with buying securing deploying and
maintaining desktops is estimated by
many analysts to be as much as 64 for
more of an annual IT budget a recent
study by Gartner suggested that the true
total cost of ownership of an unmanaged
pc can be almost six thousand dollars
this might sound like a very high number
but we're partners specializes in
understanding and being able to quantify
the real costs of PC ownership first we
have the acquisition of the hardware and
the software applications that run on
top of the pc then I teashops need to
worry about deploying configuring and
maintaining the hour if this happens to
be in remote side branch offices or home
workers that only increases the cost
then you have to deploy my and maintain
the software applications running on
those on top of those desktops including
application updates patches service
packs antivirus firewall etc so this can
be a tedious task there's also
significant information security
challenges PCs are traditionally prone
to theft and vulnerable to attacks and
also there's mobility limitations since
all your data is tied to a particular PC
you even if you have a laptop you have
to be in front of that laptop to be able
to access your data and applications so
there has been multiple desktop
computing alternatives that have emerged
and the one we're going to focus on
today is desktop virtualization as one
of the potential solutions to this to
some of these challenges so let's
continue by defining what desktop
virtualization is let's look at a
physical desktop first again the
physical desktop is informed of four
major components you have the hardware
you have the operating system in most of
the cases that is a Windows operating
system that is installed on that
physical hardware
you have the applications that is there
installed on the on top of that
operating system and you have the user
data which is the personal files the
profile the settings the configuration
the wallpaper for that particular user
all these components are again tightly
coupled you have different users have
different settings and personalization
for applications and for the operating
system which means that if you have two
different users you have two totally
different environments that you have the
IP shops need to manage and maintain
making things very complex do you in
theory could end up having different
versions of operating system different
combinations of applications on top of
those physical systems and obviously
different personal data on those systems
the first step in desktop virtualization
is to run the virtual desktops as
virtual desktops on top of a hypervisor
what this makes it is that it makes
desktops portable one can conceptually
run now the desktop on top of a server
you can run it on top of a PC or you
could put your desktop in on a USB taken
and take it with you IT managers
typically consolidate desktops into a
single server or server farms and so the
users can connect remotely to them it's
also important to note here that however
virtualization is a little bit more
complex when comparing it to server
virtualization because you need to also
optimize the virtualization of
additional components such as the
monitor the user experience for the for
the visual applications for multimedia
applications has to be rich you also
have to virtualize USB peripherals
research might want to use USB scanners
they might want to use webcams connected
to their virtual desktops and audio
peripherals microphones and and headsets
so the apps user data and operating
system eyes are still tightly coupled as
we see so the next step in desktop
virtualization is to uncouple those
components by introducing 22 new
layers we have the application
virtualization layer which which
abstract the layers where were
applications get installed onto this
allows IT managers to manage all these
applications independently and you have
the user profile virtualization layer
which allows one to separate all the
user data including the files
configurations and settings from the
operating system and the applications in
summary desktop virtualization
technologies allow IT managers to manage
all components of the desktop stack
independently you can now have a single
image of windows being Windows XP Vista
or Windows 7 that you have to manage and
maintain and a single instance of your
applications to manage and obtain an
update and user data is added
dynamically to these environments
depending on what user logs into what
virtual machine let's now look at a
simple deployment scenario to see how
all these pieces will work together at
the core of desktop virtualization we
have the virtualization infrastructure
which is running all the virtual
desktops in this particular case we see
three different users run a three
different virtual machines running in
this virtualization infrastructure then
on the other side we have the client
devices client devices can be pcs thin
clients laptops smartphones the netbooks
and the one in theory can connect to
these virtual machines from from any
device same clients are typically used
for for desktop virtualization because
people don't want to avoid having a
separate PC at the on the desk thin
client is a stateless device it has the
minimum firmware required to establish a
remote connection to that virtual
desktop and in essence it's like the
cell like a cable business where the
syncline is a setup box that displays
information remotely
so how does it how do these devices do
that they there is a remoting protocol
and the remoting protocol is what is
actually connecting the end device where
the user is interacting to as a virtual
desktop allah a lot of innovation has
been happening in this space there's a
unique requirements as we've said they
for the content on the desktop are
dynamic and it they vary with time so
you need to have a really good
virtualization of your display you need
to allow users to connect peripherals to
these client devices and make them
appear on the virtual desktops as if
they were connected directly to to those
virtual machines so in essence we're
tricking the operating systems and as we
will see there's several companies that
have invested in this area next to be
able to assign virtual desktops to the
different clients we have a connection
broker and the connection broker is
essentially the brain behind the whole
operation the connection broker
authenticates users and assign them to
different virtual machines and also if
the virtual machines are dormant or nate
they need to be created on the fly
that's what the connection broker would
would do and as we can see again we
desktop virtualization provides
ubiquitous access because now you can
connect to your virtual desktop from
from any device to summarize these are
the components that we just discussed we
have the virtualization infrastructure
with which one's the virtual desktops we
have the client devices which can be pcs
thin clients laptops smartphones we have
the connection broker which procures the
connections between users and virtual
desktops feed of 10 tickets users and it
manages the virtual desktops overall and
we have the remoting protocols which
allow users to connect monitors
keyboards mice and all the peripherals
to the client device to be able to
interact with the with a virtual desktop
some of the
major protocols are rdp HDX ICA and the
PC over IP so next step is going to be
to look at a little bit more advanced
deployment scenario in this particular
setup we now have users connecting over
the land over the internet so we have a
branch office this could be for back for
example and we have 3g or Wi-Fi wireless
connected devices for security reasons
the first step in this type of
deployment would be to add a secure
gateway the secure gateway will be the
only component sitting on a DMZ for the
company and is a component that will
actually authenticate the users and make
sure that the highest security standards
are used to between the clients
connecting from the internet to the
virtual desktops here's where one can
also add two factor authentication
requirements to into increased security
practices even more next since we have
users connecting over the Internet
people sometimes deploy one accelerators
one accelerate readers what they do is
they improve the performance of the
protocols over the web as an example we
have customers today where they that are
running the virtual infrastructure in
the US and they have branch offices in
in places like India China so we see
connections that are running over very
long long lengths that are actually
performing quite well when we introduce
one acceleration and protocol
acceleration technologies on top of
these connections next we have the
application of virtualization layer and
this is the software that allows IT
managers to manage the applications in
the penalty from the virtual desktops we
have the user profile layer which allows
one to manage the user profiles and
finally the OS image management and
ideally again we would have a single
image for each of the different
operating opera
in systems that that I t count that IT
groups are offering to their customers
to summarize again we introduced the
security gateway which provides enhanced
security and one connectivity we have
the application virtualization layer
which encapsulates applications to
enhance their portability and
manageability we have the user profile
virtualization which decouples the user
components from the operating system and
applications we have one optimization
technologies which can optimize the
performance of all the protocols over
high latency low bandwidth and loss in
networks and finally we have additional
protocol enhancements that can provide
an additional layer on top of the
remoting protocols to deliver improve
user experience and increased
scalability on the back end as we have
seen there are many components in the
desktop virtualization let's look at
some of the players this is a very busy
slide and I won't go into the details
it's just to give you a reference as you
will see there's well stablish companies
such as Microsoft Citrix vmware wise HP
as well as many startups in this space
and I've tried to include mainly the
major players there's been significantly
consolidation by acquisitions in this
space and the companies like Microsoft
VMware Citrix and a PHP have acquired
many startups in the last couple of
years so let's now look at some of the
important deployment factors that that
IT managers need to take into account to
see if desktop virtualization is right
for them when the one of the most
important factors is to understand the
user need users can be classified in in
four different types we classify them as
past workers and has workers are users
that use a handful of applications they
mainly do task task entry and
task type of operations and they have
need for limited peripherals these are
the space word technologies for for
session virtualization which is another
alternative to to desktop virtualization
have been very very successful and
that's where company were products like
Citrix presentation server now called
sanap and Microsoft terminal server has
been have been very successful next we
have the knowledge workers knowledge
workers are arguably the majority of the
workers and they need to access a
variety of applications they need to
have multimedia reach applications be
able to connect multiple multiple
peripherals to their to their machines
next we have the mobile work workers and
this is a fast growing area of the
population one needs to be able to
connect from laptops in a disconnected
mode when sitting on a on an airplane or
you need to be able to connect on the go
over 3G wireless connections and finally
we have the specialty workers specialty
workers are the types of applications
that would fall on the other three
categories and here as an example we
could have intensive video editing
applications advanced 3d graphic
applications high-definition video
conferencing or or scenarios where the
network contact connectivities is poor
so desktop virtualization has a
potential to cover most of these type of
workers but he has some limitations to
be able the green area represents the
the area that we're desktop
virtualization is being positioned for
and the arrows represent some of the
investments that the industry has been
making to expand this area the Earth's
as we mentioned being significant
investments in the protocol side to be
able to deliver good user experience as
user experience without compromise for
multimedia for USB devices real-time
sound applications there's also
major investment on the mobile user a
case where companies have introduced the
concept of online offline virtual
desktops where one can actually check
out a virtual desktop into a laptop to
be able to work offline or one or
technologies that would allow users to
connect remotely over 3g and Wi-Fi
connections the use cases for for users
in the company are also very important
when developing the financial model
because these will determine the
scalability as a rule of thumb the one
will need for example five what one will
be able to run five to 12 users per CPU
core and depending on what kind of
workers you one has this number could be
higher or lower let's look at some
additional deployment factors to be
considered we have the application and
user profile management options that the
companies need to need to analyze one
can do pulled virtual desktops and this
is the concept where there's little
personalization on the desktops we
assume under this scenario that that the
accounting who will have a type of
desktop with a given set of applications
and the finance group will have a
different type of desktop so we create
polls and dynamically assign different
users to those different pools we could
also have persistent virtual machines
where every user has a dedicated virtual
machine or we could use a profile and
application virtualization technologies
that we discussed next we have the
search strategy and the key thing here
is that that the server great storage is
expensive so people use technologies
like operating system streaming so that
they can use a single image that is
shared among all virtual desktops
there's technologies from from storage
vendors to do
the duplication and compression of the
images that are stored on the on the
fondant on the sand and the nests and
the ice cassie storage and there's
technologies like linked clones from
companies like vmware where one has a
golden image and all other VMS are are
deployed as delta files for that golden
image next we have the security strategy
and this is a very important factor one
is to first decide if there's if
connectivity is going to be given to
people outside of the corporate land and
if doing so wanted to decide if if
you're going to use a VPN or an ssl
gateway there's also different remote
protocol encryption levels from very
simple to state-of-the-art encryption
and same thing with authentication with
people using smart cards for to subtly
two-factor authentication RSA two-factor
authentication and even fingerprint
readers or other biometrics biometrics
next we need to decide whether to
support or not branch offices one can't
you can have a centralized architecture
or a distributed architecture with
virtual machines running on the branch
themselves the one support is also very
important because they wanted to
understand that the type of connectivity
that users are going to have when they
are connecting either from home or from
from other countries it's important to
understand the network network
conditions next we need to consider
whether we're going to use pcs or think
lines in the deployment pcs have some
advantages for example they always have
the latest versions of the remoting
protocols and the microsoft licensing
costs are lower when when using a pc as
a client device the sink lines on the
other hand they have other benefits they
have a much longer depreciation recycle
the last longer they have less
management and in fact some of the
analyst numbers that we're going to
present our old based on customers using
think line as a client device finally
there's also a
sourcing options that one needs to
consider in the world of cloud computing
there's companies starting to offer
desktops as a service and those can run
in either a private cloud or a public
cloud so companies like IBM and
different telcos are starting to offer
and startups are starting to offer these
services which is a very interesting
area so what are the challenges of
virtual desktops first and foremost it's
the initial investment one needs to make
sure that the companies need to make
sure they have the right servers are
right storage the right networking
infrastructure and software to be able
to run virtual desktops so there can be
a significant investment upfront and
what people do is they typically wait
for a hardware refresh cycle to
introduce to introduce a virtual
desktops next one is to understand the
limitations for the different type of
users mobile and special is specialty
users they have unique requirements that
might not be addressed by by virtual
desktops yet but we're getting there
next yes virtualizing desktops is not
good enough if you are if one is going
to virtualize desktops wanted to make
sure that they have good management
strategies with good business and and
business processes and policies make
sure that the components that you use
can interoperate don't don't make a big
investment and then find your fully
dependent on a particular vendor as we
said there's network connectivity
concerns regarding bandwidth a latency
packet loss there's also kirtle cultural
transition challenges users have to see
the benefits of virtual desktops in
order to let go of their pcs and finally
there's a microsoft licensing microsoft
just announced some new licensing a
couple of weeks ago and to be able to do
virtual desktops most companies need to
either have Software Assurance for their
client devices or they need to pay
virtual desktop access license of one
hundred dollars per year let's now
continue and summarize some of the
benefits of a virtual desktop computing
there are costs and business benefits to
virtual desktops when compared to the
physical pcs there's based on our
research study there's a total cost of
ownership savings of two to ten percent
comparing it when comparing pcs to
virtual desktops these numbers are
assuming that the customers are using a
thin client as the client device and the
savings when comparing an unmanaged
desktop with a managed virtual desktop
deployment can be as high as forty three
percent there are several business
benefits as well security privacy
privacy and compliance benefits with
virtual desktops empty threat software
can be enforced and does not need to be
installed on the desktop just protect
your servers privacy of data is a huge
problem with theft of mobile computers
or the theft of hard disks for computer
desktops when using virtual desktops
users can take data and let they are
authorized making virtual desktops great
for banks and health care to ensure
customers data ours are staying private
no data is stored on the client device
which simplifies adherence to some
regulations such as socks keeper and
basil to regulations when using thin
clients desktops are units that are no
longer prone to theft since they become
useless without a server the centralized
management aspects are also very strong
virtual desktops and clients allow for
more control points for IT
administrators this eliminates for
reduces IT visit to desktops and fix
activities are also significantly
reduced the backup strategies also
significantly improved since all the
information now is installed in
in a single file there are significantly
reliability benefits virtual desktops
are running on server grade hardware
which is less prone to failures and same
thing holds true for the clients when
using a syncline rapid deployment and
disaster recovery once your data center
installation is in place adding users is
easy and the need of IT staff on branch
offices can be minimized virtual
desktops are great as a disaster
recovery strategy since no data is
stored at the desktop itself but only in
the data center and collocations
recovery centers are easy and
inexpensive to set up in the case of an
event next we have the green computing
benefits with less significantly less
power less noise less cooling required
and finally we have mobility benefits
since we're running on virtual desktops
we can connect to our data from anywhere
and they it's funny the other day where
we released actually a product for for
mobile workers called pocketcloud and we
we've received great stories on the
usage of that there's people that now
think they can be connected to their
desktops on the go wherever they are if
something happens they always have
connectivity so let me now highlight
some of the other important trends in
desktop virtualization as we mentioned
there's public and private desktop as a
service the companies that are coming
out the some big some small this will be
a very interesting area in cloud
computing in the coming years it were
companies might be able to outsource
their whole their holy desktop computing
next we have the area of client
hypervisors and offline virtual desktops
companies like VMware Citrix Microsoft
they are making sure that there's good
online capabilities on virtual desktop
computing so that users can can check
out and they also operate when there's
no connectivity
there's a significantly integration of a
technology stat is tag going on with the
acquisitions and this can be expected in
the coming years there's storage
virtualization technologies that are
coming out to reduce the cost of storage
and another strong trend that we're
seeing is that of what it's called zero
client a special type of thin clients
that have a no operating system it's
just minor firmware and the operates
again as as if it was a back to the dumb
terminal years but with with a lot more
IP on these boxes so the companies are
trying to minimize the management on the
client side and CEO clients are giving a
very cost-effective and a secure
solution to this as we have this we have
discussed two major desoll competing
models we've discussed the PC model and
the virtual desktop model this light is
also mainly for completeness we wanted
to leave you with a message that there's
other desktop computing model help out
there that that they wanted to evaluate
as well there's the web client model
which is basically a model where
everything is the browser-based this is
what the Google is pushing with things
like their Chrome OS Chrome operating
system for example another computing
model is that of a session
virtualization that's where Citrix a nap
Microsoft terminal servers play this is
mainly targeted for task workers and
tempered it can offer significant cost
savings there's also a new religious in
this space within Microsoft multi-point
server being released a couple of months
ago and this is mainly targeted for the
education and emerging markets and the
the savings with this kind type of
computing can be great but it again
there are some limitations with them one
can get two terminals for under a
hundred dollars so it makes it a very
cheap and afford
and finally we have stream desktops and
the concept of stream desktops is when
we actually move the hard drive of a
machine to the data center so all the
execution of the applications is local
on the PC but all the storage is managed
centrally will try to cover some of
these desktop computing models as part
of the future class at Stanford so in
summary we've covered the different
market trends we looked at the
challenges a for IT companies beyond on
managing their desktops we've looked at
with giving an overview of virtual
desktop computing and we'll discuss the
technologies diploma and architectures
and the ecosystem of a virtual desktop
computing and finally we've looked at
some of the challenges and benefits of
desktop virtualization in closing the
desktop virtualization is still a new
technology that is rapidly maturing with
the help of various startups and some
heavyweight IT professionals and
entrepreneurs should monitor closely
this paste since it'd my bringing
opportunities he has the potential to
reduce costs and bring various business
benefits but customers have to evaluate
the solution carefully to see if they
meet their needs let me now turn it back
to Michelle to continue with a webinar
Thank You Daniels for your participation
today the topic that you've just heard
about is part of a new course in our
summer quarter portfolio called leading
trends and information technology which
is offered by the management science and
engineering department and under the
course number ms ND 236 the course is
taught by dr. daniel barreto and
professor Samuel chu and will focus on
the trends and disruptive technologies
and IT emphasis will be given to the
wave technologies create a competitive
edge and generate business value there
will be a broad range of views presented
by different guest speakers including
top-level executives of technology
companies and IT executives at the CIO
level of Fortune 100 companies the
course will have a special emphasis on
technology such as virtualization cloud
computing security
and unified communications on campus
attendance is encouraged if at all
possible to provide a great networking
opportunity to participants it'll be
offered for three units of graduate
credit and as it's a new course in our
portfolio we will not make it available
for auditing this year enrollment for
this particular course is open now so
please go to our website at SCPD
stanford.edu and submit your enrollment
today at this point I'd like to conduct
our final poll to find out if you are
interested in this course if you're
interested in enrolling in this course
msme 236 leading trends and information
technology and while you're submitting
your responses i'm going to ask the
speaker to respond to some of the
questions that we received from our
audience today thank you michelle is
we've had a couple of questions around
network requirements for desktop
virtualization he pointed out there's a
importantly requirements on the on the
network side on average the amount of
traffic that we see desktop virtual
desktop consume is anywhere between 100
and 300 kilo bits per second but those
numbers can go up depending on the type
of activity the user is performing it to
address these network challenges
companies that one-half the centralized
management of their desktops they are
adding the offline capabilities for
virtual desktop so that they can manage
the images for their desktop centrally
as well as the application and the user
data and when users have good
connectivity they can actually check out
the full version of their desktop to run
on any platform they can check it out on
a USB stick USB sticks they can check it
out onto a laptop they can't run the
desktop locally on a plane or on a place
with bad connectivity and then when they
have good connectivity the data gets
synchronized on the back end so that
some of the technologies are coming up
to try to improve this in hopefully that
addresses that question is another area
to me under
and is in the area hey of cloud
computing desktop as a service we were
getting some questions around that so as
we said there's different desktop
computing models and different different
models are addressed to different a type
of users desktop virtualization is
definitely a model mainly tailor for
enterprises the one can fall for small
medium businesses and for consumers
there's all their solutions out there
and we're going to be covering those as
part of the class here at Stanford okay
so thank you so much that's right oh I'm
going to go ahead and close the polls
and we will continue to answer questions
for those of you that have submitted
questions that weren't answered live and
now I'd like to give you some background
on the Stanford center for professional
development our Center serves as a
bridge between Stanford University and
industry offering academic and
professional education courses and
programs to meet the career long
education needs of engineers scientists
technology professionals managers and
executives the Stanford center for
professional development has been a part
of the Silicon Valley extending Stanford
education for 40 years and based on
customer feedback having access to
Stanford level education is critical
maintaining a competitive position in
the marketplace the Stanford center for
professional development offers
approximately 250 graduate courses that
can be taken for academic credit without
having to be formally admitted to a
degree program we also offer bundles of
courses or graduate certificates
comprised of three to five courses in a
guided curriculum of study which offers
not only Stanford University graduate
credit but also an in-depth subject
specific knowledge the Stanford center
for professional development also
extends master's degrees to industry
through the honors cooperative program
candidates must apply like any other
graduate students and if admitted can
pursue their degree in a part-time basis
over the course of five
years up to 18 units of graduate credit
earned under the non-degree option may
later be applied toward a master's
degree we also offer the option to audit
courses this program allows you to take
graduate courses online without homework
exams or interaction with the teaching
staff auditing a course is a great way
to update your knowledge without paying
the full tuition rate the live course
lectures at Stanford University are
tapes digitized and made available
online if you enroll in one of our
online courses you'll have access to the
recorded lectures 24 hours a day seven
days a week for the duration of the
academic quarter which allows you to
keep pace with the class on campus each
lecture is made available online
approximately one hour after the
conclusion of the live lecture if the
course that you that you take requires
you to submit homework that work would
also be submitted to the Stanford center
for professional development there we
receive log and deliver your homework to
the instructor this can be done either
by fax or by email if you are required
to take exams these will be sent to your
exam monitor the person that you have
designated to receive the exam
administer the exam according to
guidelines provided by the course
instructor and return it to the Stanford
center for professional development an
exam monitor may not be your spouse
friend or family member typically an
exam monitor will be your manager or
someone in the HR opposite your company
the enrollment period for summer quarter
actually opens on April 12 but it will
remain open through wednesday june 16
again the course that you just heard
about is available for enrollment now if
you're interested in enrolling in any of
our graduate courses offered to the
Stanford center for professional
development you must do so online
through our website at SCPD stanford.edu
an official sealed academic transcript
must be submitted however we do accept
copies while the official transcript is
in route to ition is broken down into
two categories member company and
non-member company the non degree option
tuition is thirteen hundred dollars per
unit however if you work for a company
who has a membership with the Sanford
Center for professional development the
tuition is reduced to eleven hundred
dollars per unit most of our courses in
the Graduate portfolio are between two
and four
unit the audit option is eleven hundred
and fifty dollars per course and it's
you work for a member company the
tuition is reduced to nine hundred and
ninety five dollars per course if you
are unsure about whether your company
has a membership with the Stanford
center for professional development or
if you would like to learn about the
benefits available to member companies I
encourage you to contact us access the
student account information free
webinars seminars like the one that
you've just participated in course
enrollment and online videos is
available through my Stanford connection
on the SDPD website finally I'd like to
highlight an upcoming webinar that we
have scheduled for Tuesday the twentieth
of April at eleven o'clock a.m. about
the growing threat and impact of
web-based malware over two million
websites have been infected in the past
year doubling the number of web pages
infected with malware in the last
quarter compared to a year ago in this
live webinar neil des lani co-founder of
internet security company dashians will
present data from the past year
analyzing the growth of infections and
show how webmasters can take a holistic
approach to preventing detecting
containing and recovering from such
attacks the presentation will also focus
on discussing how IT professionals can
mitigate the threat of web-based malware
infections by using a variety of
resources and technologies today's
presentation has been recorded and will
be sending out the link to all
registrants if you wish to print the
slide decks from this webinar simply
click on the handouts icon located in
the upper right side toolbar next to the
feedback icon we welcome inquiries and
follow-up and will remain on the line to
answer any questions remaining in the
queue thank you very much for your
attendance today
you